[Musica]
amico guarda ciò che ti dico il mondo
che tu senti è lo stesso che io vedo
dammi la tua mano sento la tua mano
dicono che sono sordo ma io vedo gli
uccelli cantare ed il vento sugli alberi
e i bambini ridere il mio universo è
vuoto senza di te
guardami e sorridimi e stringe la mia
mano nella tua dammi la tua mano e
impara la mia lingua
io posso parlare per segni nell'aria noi
possiamo raggiungere le stelle ci sono
tante cose da fare insieme
anonimo francese sordo e innegabile
apparentemente c'è un grande divario tra
la lingua dei segni e la lingua vocale
io oggi sono qui per parlarvi di ciò che
accomuna queste due lingue italiani
siamo conosciuti e riconosciuti nel
mondo per le nostre abilità comunicative
in particolare il nostro gesticolare il
primo aspetto che voglio condividere con
voi e che i segni non sono i gessi che
comunemente l'utente utilizza in una
normale conversazione i gessi sono privi
di significato non hanno nessuna regola
grammaticale i segni invece sono parole
che hanno una vera realtà linguistica e
sono formati rispettando regole
morfologiche sintattiche e semantiche e
fonologiche ben precise
tali regole che permettono la creazione
di un segno sono chiamati parametri
formaziona lì e sono la configurazione
ovvero la forma che assume la mano
nell'eseguire il segno qui vediamo
l'esempio del segno mamma il luogo dove
viene eseguito il segno l'orientamento
la direzione verso cui si orienta il
palmo della mano e il movimento della
mano nell'eseguire il segno studi
linguistici più recenti hanno
individuato un quinto parametro le
componenti non manuali la cosiddetta
comunicazione non verbale
l'espressione del viso il movimento
degli occhi della bocca delle
sopracciglia lo spostamento della testa
lo spostamento del corpo il principio
che ha guidato l'identificazione di
questi parametri è un principio classico
della lingua italiana quello della
coppia minima
faccio un esempio due parole simili mela
e vela cambiano completamente di
significato perché si differenziano di
un fonema fune ma m fonema v con lo
stesso principio può essere analizzata
la lingua dei segni
la coppia minima si distingue sulla base
dei quattro parametri se cambia un solo
parametro cambia completamente il
significato del segno
faccio anche qui un esempio il segno
mamma e il segno scusa sono due segni
identici in tre parametri l'orientamento
il movimento e la configurazione cambia
soltanto il luogo di esecuzione luogo di
esecuzione mamma e la guancia luogo di
esecuzione scusa e il mento
storicamente fu il linguista william
stock
a rivelare questa scoperta attraverso
una ricerca sistematica della lingua dei
segni americana american sign language
vedete abbiamo la conferma questa è una
lingua ricca ed articolata capace di
suscitare emozione di creare una
meravigliosa simbiosi con l'altro di
esprimere qualsiasi concetto concreto un
astratto con un'unica differenza che
invece di usare il canale acustico
verbale utilizza quello visivo manuale
incredibile però ci avesse mai pensato
né tutti diamo per scontata la
comprensione
eppure nemmeno ci rendiamo conto di
quanto importante e fondamentale sia nei
rapporti umani gli effetti che la
comprensione produce sono molteplici
se solo compreso mi sento accettato
non mi sento più solo io il mio
interlocutore
siamo più vicini non c'è più distanza
se qualcuno comprende ciò che ho dentro
lo vedo meglio anch'io di conseguenza
conosco meglio me stesso non solo se
qualcuno comprende ciò che io sto
esprimendo diventa più reale perché lo
vediamo in due la comprensione è
un'esigenza imprescindibile per ognuno
di noi
scusatemi
credetemi si trarrebbero molti benefici
non solo anche sul profilo pedagogico è
curioso le analisi sullo sviluppo del
linguaggio del bambino dimostrano che
bambino sordo e bambino dente nel primo
anno di vita hanno le stesse capacità
la scelta sul canale acustico verbale o
quello visivo manuale dipende dall'input
linguistico a cui viene esposto il
bambino ovviamente la lingua orale non
può essere la prima lingua per un
bambino che nasce sordo o lo diventa nel
primo anno di vita perché non potendo
year e non riuscirebbe ad acquisire la
capacità del linguaggio parlato nello
stesso modo e nello stesso tempo in cui
questo avviene nel bambino dante quindi
voi ben capire che i segni sono
fondamentali per la crescita di un
bambino sordo perché rispondono
pienamente alle esigenze cognitive
espressive e comunicative
differentemente avrà difficoltà a
relazionarsi con il prossimo e ad
esprimersi al meglio
rimanendo di fatto chiuso dentro una
prigione di silenzio e di solitudine e
ricordiamoci che non c'è persona più
sola di chi si sente diverso tra i
propri simili
in pochi sanno che la sordità
rappresenta un difetto molto frequente e
colpisce in italia all'incirca un
bambino su 1000 nati
eppure va evidenziato che il nostro
paese insieme a malta e lussemburgo non
ha ancora dato il riconoscimento
giuridico della lingua
nonostante nel 2009 ha sancito la
convenzione dell'onu sui diritti della
disabilità che invitava tutti gli stati
membri a ratificare tale legge
un passo importante cessato nel 2017
quando il senato della repubblica
italiana ha accolto le richieste e gli
appelli del mondo silente approvando un
disegno di legge numero 302 che
riconosce e tutela i diritti delle
persone sorde la scelta della modalità
di comunicazione i percorsi formativi da
fare e promuove l'inclusione scolastica
e lavorativa
questo ha dato speranza al mondo dei
sordi
tutto ciò che vi esposto mi ha portato
ad una riflessione che nonostante la
sordità sia un deficit invisibile
meriterebbe più attenzione da parte
nostra ma soprattutto il rispetto della
sua lingua e intesa come espressione di
cultura di una comunità che ha
un'identità ben definita che va oltre lo
stato medico della semplice di
disabilità sensoriale perché vi ho
parlato di lingua dei segni e di sordità
il mio desiderio è quello di riuscire a
trasmettervi un po della curiosità e
della passione che mi animano
quando parlo di questo argomento questa
foto magnifico momento potrebbe essere
qualsiasi donna presente in questa sala
e io ricordo bene il racconto di mia
madre della sua disperazione nel momento
in cui mi stava dando alla luce davanti
a lei c'erano medici e sanitari con la
bocca coperta dalla mascherina era
disorientata non sapeva bene cosa stesse
succedendo
istintivamente reagì strappando via la
mascherina dalla bocca di un medico
voleva percepire la parola o quanto
dicevano per affrontare il travaglio del
parto non potendo leggere le loro labbra
non aveva idea di ciò che stavano
dicendo e di come la stavano guidando in
quello che doveva essere il momento più
bello è magico della sua vita sono
privilegiata
sono figlia di genitori sordi ma sono
anche cresciuta tra enormi difficoltà
procurati dall'ignoranza della società e
ho saputo trasformarli solo in punti di
forza in età matura
questo è uno dei tanti disagi che la
società ignora oppure ricordo un altro
episodio frequentavo le elementari e
all'uscita di scuola
vedevo le mamme dei miei compagni che
signorini riunivano in gruppo la mia era
sempre da sola in disparte
io avrei voluto avvicinarmi a quelle
mamme e chiedere loro perchè non parlate
con la mia mamma ma chissà forse lo
avrebbero fatto se solo avessero avuto
la capacità di farsi comprendere se solo
avessero avuto la conoscenza della
modalità comunicativa visiva
il mio sogno è quello che più persone
possibili scoprano questa realtà e
aumentino lo sforzo per risanarla come
ha indicato il sordo francese nella
poesia dell'inizio che con semplicità
rivolge appello ma allo stesso tempo
istruisce gli ignari di quanto bella
possa essere la diversità della lingua
umana costruita con ingegnosa abilità
che tende la mano per scaldarsi e
fondersi con i rumori del mondo che vede
con gli occhi
basta davvero poco per contribuire a
migliorare il mondo intorno a noi e ad
essere più inclusivi
grazie
[Applauso]